une production du studio SF
bienvenue au sans filtre
au changement de le podcast nous
inviter datite CPH Quentin avec moi dôme
plante on va dans l'espoir aujourd'hui
c'est bon
aujourd'hui on va dans l'espace avec
Farah Albi c'était un réel plaisir de la
recevoir les ingénieurs aérospatial à
travail à nul autre que la NASA
elle a travaillé entre autres sur le
projet persévérance qui est un robot qui
ont envoyé sur Mars pour recueillir des
des symptômes qui a envoyé des données
ici à un parcours vraiment fascinant
elle vient aussi de sortir un livre
mon année martienne à la grande majorité
de nos auditeurs qui sont en version
juste audio ça vaut la peine de
mentionner
dans la caméra livre vraiment fascinant
je suis en pleine lecture de ce livre et
puis on parle de son travail de
scientifiques d'ingénieurs mais aussi
beaucoup de son histoire l'histoire de
sa famille les difficultés qu'à le
rencontrer au gros de sa vie étant une
femme d'origine indienne grandi à
Joliette
c'est vraiment super fascinant je pense
que je vous encourage à vous procurer le
livre et de découvrir cette personne
incroyable on est allé vraiment dans
pleine direction dans le podcast on a
parlé de vie dans le cosmos on a parlé
de son travail spécifiquement qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait au jour le jour parler de
mars parler
on exploré l'univers carrément c'est
exactement ça qu'on a fait c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait c'est le fun
parce que Farin est vraiment
cash wall puis les bacs qui sont quand
même conceptuellement assez avancé mais
de façon super légère et facile d'accès
on arrive beaucoup ouais c'est vraiment
une bonne vulgarisatrice aussi tu as su
vraiment dans
ce qu'elle explique puis c'est des fois
ça fait peur
[Musique]
dans une galaxie près de chez vous le
gars qui font juste se promener play
hier soir genre des des messages comme
avec les statistiques de la planète
qui serait habitable plus ils vont tuer
de faire ça
ben oui mais on est on est
je pense qu'on est loin mais d'être
capable de voir une planète puis de dire
celle-là les des trucs intéressants
ressemblent à terre déjà un peu rendu là
puis on va l'aide de plus en plus c'est
vraiment fascinant je pense que je peux
brûler du podcast mais c'est pareil
qu'on convaincu que
ça fait le podcast c'est ce qu'on fait
là on regarde la tension tout autour
est assez convaincu que s'il y a de la
vie dans les sur s'il y a eu la vie
aussi il y a de la vie dans le système
solaire sur Mars ou ailleurs on va le
savoir le de notre divorce que de notre
vivant possiblement à nous c'est assez
formidable c'est assez impressionnant
c'est fly c'est capote merci
conversation bon podcast
le podcast aujourd'hui est présenté par
challenge you challenge you qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est une plateforme en ligne
qui vous aide à décrocher votre diplôme
d'études secondaires alors pour toutes
les personnes maintenant adulte qui
aurait pas terminé le secondaire pour
toutes sortes de raisons challenge you
est là pour vous c'est en ligne c'est
100% gratuit cette compagnie de vrais
professeur tout au long du processus
dans vos études dans vos examens vous
vous déplacez seulement à la fin de tout
le processus pour aller faire votre
examen du ministère dans un centre de
formation aux adultes sinon tout ce tout
se fait selon vos termes vous étudier le
matin le soir vous pouvez faire 8 heures
de français une journée 8h des maths de
l'autre vous pouvez faire des cours de
maths français anglais de secondaire 3 4
et 5 et c'est tout dans un environnement
ludique c'est super le fun c'est fait de
manière amicale si être sur les bancs
d'école en fait il vous déplacer à
chaque jour pour aller dans une classe
c'est pas fait pour vous mais Challenger
est possiblement la solution pour vous
pour vous aider à décrocher ce bon vue
diplôme parce que ça peut quand même
servir dans la vie un diplôme d'état
secondaire c'est quand même avoir une
bonne corde à avoir à son arc ici on a
des moyens comme challenger de faciliter
l'obtention de son diplôme mais pourquoi
pas en profiter alors je vous encourage
à y aller à foncer à mettre l'effort à
redoubler d'ardeur pour atteindre pour
décrocher son diplôme travaux vraiment
la peine alors challenge you allez
checker ça ça vaut vraiment la peine
let's go le podcast aujourd'hui est
présenté par menscape menscape qui sont
les meilleurs produits pour homme pour
le soin du corps de la pilosité pour
l'entretien du corps de l'homme et de
n'importe qui en fait
Mindscape moi c'est des produits que
j'adore que j'utilise au quotidien
vraiment pour la gestion comme je disais
de la pilosité ben le fameux landmore
4.0 qui est ici c'est vraiment le
meilleur outil
dans la douche ça va vraiment super bien
il y a pas petit poil qui reste
président
il y a des crèmes hydratantes pour le
corps il y a le tonner c'est vraiment
complet et là il y a un nouveau produit
en fait
qui vient toujours d'annoncer on l'a pas
encore reçu en fait je l'ai pas avec moi
ça devrait être arrivé dans la boîte à
lettres très bientôt et c'est le beer
alors vraiment une tondeuse électrique
spécialement faite pour la barbe
connaissant la qualité des produits
médical ça risque d'être révolutionnaire
à fait ça risque d'être le meilleur la
meilleure tondeuse que jamais eu sur le
marché il est juste disponible pour la
commander sur le site moi je la
recommande c'est sur J'aime pas encore
essayé puis je la recommande il y a plus
de 20 ajustements de longueur pour votre
barbe en fait donc que vous aimez ça
très court moyen de Manco un petit peu
plus long vous pouvez vraiment avoir en
fait le look
costum pratiquement pour vous le look
exact que vous désirez vous allez
pouvoir la voir avec la précision la
plus la plus pure de chez manscape donc
on n'hésite pas ah non on a un code
promo pour 20% de rabais c'est sans
filtre en un mot sans filtre
donc on profite des bons produits
manscape moi je les recommande j'irai
j'irai la guerre pour m'inscrire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parfait ça roule merci d'être là merci
d'utiliser de cette plage horaire dans
ton horaire chargé de passage à Montréal
demain aussi c'est quand même à cette
heure-là ça peut prendre 15 minutes mais
c'est une vie que je vis juste ici quand
je suis ici après je rentre à ma vie
normale est-ce que c'est plus molo ta
vie normale mais il y a plus de routines
des fois c'est sûr que c'est un peu fou
ma vie normale aussi mais pas comme
c'est pas le même genre de travail des
choses qui se passent au travail mais
j'ai pas j'ai pas un podcast ce matin
avec conférence l'après-midi
la bonne enfance ça m'a quoi une journée
typique
moi je suis une lève tôt je l'étais pas
avant mais chez le lève-tôt je vais au
gym le matin c'est la pandémie qui est
faite ça je sais plus exactement
au début quand on revenait au gym j'ai
vraiment ma jolie aller quand tu as
personne le s'est rendu que c'est juste
j'ai pas le goût de voir la montre
puis après ben c'est ça de mon travail
de jour à jour ça dépend vraiment comme
là en ce moment on est en développement
d'une nouvelle mission je travaille sur
mission qui s'appelle satellite qui va
être lancé en 2025 avec je travaille
avec un contracteur qui est au Colorado
avec des fois je suis à Los Angeles des
fois chocolat radeau puis on se prépare
à faire les tests de système ça veut
dire qu'en ce moment c'est on est on
travaille avec toutes les vendeurs c'est
comme on va acheter l'ordinateur quelque
part on va acheter le système de
communication quelque part la radio tout
ça qui ont tout comme un petit peu des
problèmes en ce moment c'est toujours
comme ça c'est c'est parfait fait que
deux jours à jour en ce moment c'est
beaucoup de travaux shooting j'appelle
Lola mais le mois prochain dans quelques
mois on va commencer comme les tests
système avec à ce moment-là on va je
vais plus au Colorado puis être le
pendant l'été mais satellites terrestre
en orbite autour de la Terre mais ça va
regarder les étoiles
puis c'est quoi
c'est quoi son objectif il y a aussi des
choses précises que oui on va pouvoir
faire que d'autres fait pas maintenant
mais c'est un télescope en infrarouge
comme James web que vous connaissez
peut-être mais James web c'est pas la
même grande à quelqu'un
ça prend des photos à très très haute
résolutions mais son champ de vue à la
caméra est plus petite nous on a un
champ de vue très très grand mais une
résolution plus basse fait que ça nous
permet ça va nous permettre de prendre
des cartes complètes du ciel
puis de le fait qu'on va prendre quatre
quatre cartes complètes effectivement
c'est un peu comme quand tu ouvres
Google Maps là tu fais un zoomer pour
voir plus près c'est ces deux différents
types de caméras il y en a qui imagine
un peu ça comme ça c'est que nous on va
faire une grosse carpe ça va leur
permettre ça va permettre à d'autres
satellites de voir ok là je vais voir ce
qui se passe là mais ça permet aussi de
faire comme des statistiques au macro de
ah regarde il y a combien de galaxies ou
c'est celle c'est comme ça que ça se
passe dans ce coin là d'avoir
une carte plus claire finalement de du
cosmos plus complète puis ça nous permet
aussi de comprendre ça va nous aider à
comprendre dans le fond au début
l'univers aussi c'est comme avec toutes
les autres informations qu'on va avoir
des autres des hôtels ça va nous
permettre de comprendre en fait
l'expansion qui s'est passé après le
après le Big Bang c'est ça le but de
comprendre ça de comprendre comment les
galaxies se forment puis aussi d'étudier
où est-ce que où est-ce que l'eau est
dans la galaxie comment l'eau se forme
mais comment les glaces se forment dans
les galaxies pour la vie ok pour ce qui
est de la Big Bang
on sait à peu près je pense
exactement
le système qui s'est passé mais en
enfance pour se faire puis là je suis
pas une astrophystisme mais même
l'expansion qui s'est passé au tout
début après le Big Bang c'est pas il y a
différents modèles qui montent à la
vitesse que ça serait exposé comment ça
se serait passé fixé on comprend un peu
ce qui s'est passé mais pas
de modèles qui qui fait en ce moment
parce qu'on a juste certaines données
peuvent avoir plus de données ça ne
comprend ça nous aidera à comprendre
exactement ce qui s'est passé c'est vrai
que ça peut retourner au tout début du
Big Bang mais avec James web ça se peut
qu'on en apprenne encore pour des
premiers moments de l'univers ouais
ça me fait capter toujours de ce genre
de de conversation là-dessus de comme
des trucs que nous au quotidien on pense
pas
là on veut comprendre le début de
l'Université de comprendre comment faire
mon café
mais toi quand tu travailles sur un sur
un télescope comme ça
tu dis que c'est du traba shooting mais
mettre en place un télescope comme ça ça
doit être infiniment compliqué le
combien y a personne qui travaille
là-dessus ce projet là il est plus petit
je dois dire pour avoir peut-être
10200 personnes c'est pas aussi grand
parce que c'est un télescope qui est
quand même plus petit tu sais quand on
parle de James web il y a déjà avoir des
milliers de personnes ça peut pas être
1000 2000 personnes plus que ça je
n'oserais pas dire le nom parce que tu
collaboration internationale la même
chose quand j'ai travaillé sur
persévérance il devait avoir mes 8000
personnes facilement qui ont travaillé
là-dessus je pense que tu pourrais aller
voir n'importe où sur mon laboratoire
puis quelqu'un aurait dit ouais j'ai
travaillé j'ai fait ce petit bouton
rouge et des lingettes en plus on a des
collaborateurs internationaux encore une
fois mais là oui l'équipe est comme nous
mon équipe
[Rires]
mais est-ce que les projets sont
chapeautés par quelqu'un sur Youtube
mettons un genre de directeur de projet
où tout le monde est tellement OK puis
il y en a un puis j'imagine que pour
être un directeur d'un projet de plein
de trinquer faut que je connaisse ton
affaire quand même aussi c'est
intéressant parce que tout le monde a
ses propres ses propres dons c'est
propre ces qualités amener un projet
avec par exemple avec quand un projet
c'est un peu comme n'importe quel projet
tu vas voir comme un project manager
avec lui c'est vraiment lui qui est en
charge comme de l'argent parce que tu as
un côté il y a un côté comme il y a des
gens qui ont des buts on peut pas juste
dépenser ce qu'on veut malheureusement
parce que c'est l'argent des taxes
avec lui c'est vraiment ça mais il faut
aussi qu'ils comprennent le côté
technique très très bien donc
normalement c'est un ingénieur parce que
justement quand il y a des risques à
prendre quand il y a des décisions à
prendre mais lui il faut qu'il comprenne
qui soit capable de comprendre mais il
faut aussi qu'il fasse confiance à son
équipe parce que tu comprendrais jamais
tout puis là en chef de projet de
l'autre côté il y a aussi un chef
technique qui est un chef indépendant à
une pour nous c'est une femme sur mon
équipe mais c'est une autorité technique
indépendante fait qu'ils sont même pas
payer par le projet son pays par
l'institution pour nous autres c'est eux
qui est comme si j'ai un problème
technique ou si j'ai quelque chose à
présenter c'est à elle que je dois
présenter ça c'est elle qui m'aide à
faire ça aussi un problème que je dis
elle
on a problème ici puis il y a personne
qui s'en occupe je peux aller la voir
elle c'est comme elle qui est en charge
côté technique puis après ça il y a
aussi une personne qui est en charge de
ce qu'on appelle le quadris avec tout ce
qui est comme les morceaux de mon
ordinateur les décisions des problèmes
qu'on a eux ils sont c'est des gens qui
ont beaucoup ces trois personnes là
c'est des gens qui ont beaucoup
d'expérience
parce que genre j'ai un doctorat moi
mais j'allais Toulouse pas toujours à
jour ça prend vraiment tout sur la job
c'est vraiment comme d'apprentissage il
y a pas de tu apprends pas grand chose à
l'école
de seconde
tu es rentré dans ce domaine là tu
rentres par la porte de plus tu poser
des questions ces questions-là de où
est-ce qu'on vient il y a de la vie
ailleurs ou plus tes messages
de l'ingénierie puis c'est plus par là
que tu es arrivé dans ce domaine là
[Rires]
comme tous les enfants peut-être le
chercher regardez les étoiles je voulais
comprendre puis c'est encore ça qui
motivent beaucoup parce que tu es en
ingénierie tu peux aller un peu partout
maintenant il y a tellement de choses
vraiment cool à faire
pour moi c'était plus ça puis
éventuellement j'étais comme ok je vais
travailler dans l'espace mais qu'est-ce
que je veux faire dans l'espace parce
qu'il y a comme tellement de métier que
je vais être scientifique est-ce que je
vais puis j'ai toujours un carnet
c'était comme ok c'est parfait on fait
les deux
la qualité de la recherche de trouver
des réponses et des questions qu'on a
toujours cherché
c'est ça que parce que tu es
ce que j'adore de ma DOP je dis pas que
je travaille toujours là mais c'est pas
pour le profit ce que je fais il y a pas
de oui on a des budgets mais il y a pas
de profit mais c'était cool
à dire quand même que c'est ce que je
fais c'est quand même un privilège de
dire que au moins je payais pour
de l'argent à quelqu'un tu ramènes des
connaissances à tout le monde dans le
fond ça j'aime ça beaucoup beaucoup de
ma job et puis il y en a des options
mais c'est dur de dire que de partir de
ça peut-être un jour qu'il y aurait
quelque chose de plus intéressant que je
me dirais oui je vais aller faire ça
là-bas mais pour l'instant c'est pas mal
tu parlais de budget à tantôt puis de
gestion de budget la question est
on parle beaucoup surtout aux États-Unis
tu sais comment on met l'argent dans
l'exploration spatiale quand mettons il
y a encore des problèmes plus micro tu
sais
à quel point est-ce que
il y a une limite monétaire à ce qu'on
peut faire à l'exploration spatiale au
sens où est-ce qu'on est limité par les
budgets qu'on a est-ce que si on avait
infini de ressources on serait vraiment
plus loin ou est-ce qu'on est comme
limité par la vitesse à laquelle on peut
progresser
je pense que c'est un peu des deux je
pense que si tu avais c'est sûr que si
tu avais un budget infini on pourrait en
faire beaucoup plus qu'on en fait parce
qu'on s'entend qui était par exemple là
en ce moment
le budget de la Nasa aux Etats-Unis
c'est moins qu'une scène pour chaque
dollar que tu payes de taxes aux
États-Unis avec c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup c'est beaucoup moins qu'une
scène même que tu payes en taxe
du budget annuel va à la NASA puis
encore deux quand on parle de ce qui va
à la NASA ça va pas juste à nous en
exploration robotique au GPN ça va à
l'exploration humaine ça va à spécifique
toutes ces compagnies là qui ont des ça
va tout ce qui est la recherche ça va
tout se montrer que c'est vraiment très
très séparé puis quand on regarde par
exemple les budgets dans les temps
d'Apollo dans les mais en 1960 on était
vers les deux trois pour ça avec quand
tu avais trois fois plus de budget c'est
sûr qu'on peut faire des choses
extraordinaires fait qu'il y a ça mais
ne ce qu'on voit dans les dernières
années c'est que oui commence à monter
mais on a une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
parce qu'il y a tellement mais c'est le
fun il y a tellement de compagnies en
érospatiale que c'est nous on
n'a pas assez de monde pour faire le
travail à faire
avec ce site c'est intéressant aussi
parce qu'on est obligé de là il y a des
projets qu'on aurait aimé faire plutôt
qu'on est obligé de ramener plus tard
parce qu'on a passé de bon mais disons
si tu avais assez de monde puis assez de
main assez d'argent puis tu avais pas
comme
je peux pas acheter un ordinateur parce
que bon si tu oublies tout ça c'est sûr
qu'on prend en faire plus je pense qu'il
y a des questions qu'on se pose qu'on
pourrait faire plus rapidement c'est
comme là l'on fait une grosse mission
pair par des ennemis comme là on a fait
persévérance on va envoyer notre mission
qui s'appelle Clipper qui va aller vers
une des lunes de Saturne de Jupiter
Europe qui est une qui a la glace autour
puis un océan en dessous
on pense qu'il y a peut-être un noyau
c'est ça qui est important parce que
c'est un noyau tu peux avoir un
transfert d'énergie avec l'eau puis
c'est ça qui puis un transfert chimique
et que ça c'est ça qui est intéressant
pour la vie
aller dans l'eau de son épaule donc
même pas imaginer les petits poissons
des chenaux
[Rires]
c'est un peu comme l'industrie
pharmaceutique c'est quand même checker
la façon avec laquelle dit-il développer
des trucs et j'imagine que ça ça
ralentit aussi beaucoup le petit mettons
tu dis pour envoyer du monde sur Mars il
faut faire une navette qui est capable
de repartir de masque si on a enlevé ce
facteur-là probablement que ça irait
plus vite oui sûrement on a on y va une
question
mais à quel point est-ce que ça c'est
mais pas un facteur limitant parce que
c'est un facteur nécessaire mais c'est
ça prend du temps mais tu vas voir que
différentes compagnies font différemment
par exemple quand tu fais ça que ça a
commencé les autres c'est comme pour la
NASA souvent on n'aime pas ça avoir des
accidents où on n'aime pas ça tu sais
que les choses marchent pas fait qu'on a
tendance à faire beaucoup beaucoup de
tests vous avez verte c'est très bien
passé mais c'était vite cette fois-ci il
y avait pas d'humain c'est encore ça
fait partie des tests pour préparer mais
avec spécial c'est quand la compagnie a
été fondée ils ont comme changé un peu
la manière qu'on fait les choses puis on
dit non non on va y aller
c'est pas grave on va avoir des
accidents c'est pour la première fusée
c'est pas drôle sur Youtube tu peux les
voir mais c'est drôle maintenant parce
qu'on sait qui ont réussi mais au début
il y en a un quiz qui ont pas fonctionné
du tout c'est comme ça qui apprenait à
chaque fois fait qui ont été capables de
faire un développement un peu plus
rapide mais même là tu regardes mes
sexes qu'il y avait l'argent plus ou
moins illimité ça prend du temps parce
que justement ok il faut que il faut
qu'on construit ça faut qu'on comprenne
ce qui s'est passé tu continues c'est
toujours un peu d'essai prennent du
temps
j'essaie de le mettre
c'est difficile à imaginer à quel point
il y a des facteurs dans une dans une
affaire comme ça tu sais parce que
mettons je veux juste prendre le thé
mettons nous ici là on monte le studio
aussi puis là à chaque étape il y a un
problème c'est enfin un test ok
qu'est-ce qui marche pas ça ça marche
pas
puis là avant d'arriver à ça ça nous a
pris genre 3 mois
pour une mini affaire là quand tu fais
une fusée c'est que tu dis tu peux venir
un ordinateur d'un fournisseur je vais
venir des cordes d'un autre fournisseur
arrive mais c'est pas une pièce tu sais
c'est
comme le notaire tu es comme le faut que
tu t'inquiètes de chaque petit morceau
dans l'ordinateur le résultat est
vieille d'eau le résultat est-ce que ça
a été construit comme il faut c'est
vraiment à ce niveau là des fois c'est
comme le mois je suis vraiment une
personne qui est comme grande grande Big
Picture c'est moi j'aime ça comprendre
les systèmes en général mais il y a du
monde que sont comme là regardez
l'ordinateurs sont comme ok le ce petit
morceau là parce qu'on a eu un problème
avec sur cette autre mission là faudrait
le changer
il y a du monde
parce que la marge petit on va parler de
persévérance mais tu es
je sais que c'est
la probabilité que que l'atterrissage se
passe mal je pense que c'est une chance
sur deux choses comme ça mais
statistiquement c'est parce que les gens
disent c'est à peu près 60% juste parce
que le nom de la période qu'on a fait
sur Mars l'étudio qui est Vinci on a
fait je sais pas combien on a fait
jusqu'à maintenant je devrais savoir
mais bon mais au début il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de missions qui sont
pas bien passées récemment bon ça c'est
quand même mieux passé mais il y a quand
même toutes sortes de facteurs qui sont
hors de notre compte comme si cette
journée-là il se passe quelque chose ou
comme par exemple moi j'ai travaillé sur
la mission inside qui atterrit sur Mars
en 2018 puis quelques mois avant ça il y
a eu une grosse tempête sur Mars c'est
ça que tu es le robot opportunity donc
c'est une grosse tempête globale comme
on en a presque jamais vu ça c'est
vraiment vraiment gros que ça a duré
super longtemps mais si c'est
tempête là s'était passé le jour de
notary stérissage je suis pas sûr qu'on
a raté parce que tu pourrais rien voir
on sait pas parce qu'on n'a jamais
atterri dans ces conditions là mais
c'est possible mais notez nous on a eu
la chance on est atterrir un mois et
demi plus tard et c'est correct ça s'est
bien passé mais c'est ça s'il y a des
choses qui sont vraiment vraiment
le nombre de
facteurs qui a calculé par considérer
juste pour envoyer un robot sur Mars
sans même compter en plus toutes les
choses hors de votre contrôle c'est
infini c'est fou là aussi on a ce qui
s'appelle un Ford protection ingénieur
clinique normalement que c'est leur job
d'être d'avoir la paranoïa c'est ce que
je pense c'est vraiment ça c'est au
niveau du système ou si au niveau de
chaque chose ok là c'est ça donc mon
ordinateur il faut que je le reparte
qu'est-ce que ça va faire comment mon
télescope est pointé par exemple est-ce
que ça pourrait changer la manière que
mon télescope est pointé pour que ça se
réchauffe trop puis là ma lentille va
être trop chaude c'est vraiment comme il
y a du monde qui font ça c'est leur job
de penser à ça c'est une femme par
exemple des fois
mon rôle m'amène à faire ça puis c'est
vraiment vraiment c'est toute une équipe
qui s'occupe de ça bref
[Musique]
l'émission persévérance dans le fond
comment tu es rentré dans ce projet-là
comment ça s'est passé
moi ça faisait
persévéen envoyé sur Mars
en février 2021 moi j'y rejoint l'équipe
en au mois de mai 2019 donc ça fait déjà
5 ans que je travaillais au jet
proportionnel qui est un descendre dans
la NASA qui est à Los Angeles les gens
t'imagines souvent que je travaille en
Floride ça comme ça tu es pas en Floride
de la NASA
non non je vis dans un état très libéral
de la Californie
mais on a 200 Californie fait que nous
on spécialise en exploration robotique
vu que moi je travaille jamais avec des
astronautes c'est toujours c'est
toujours
ça mange pas c'est facile
non pas la faire mais que ça j'avais
travaillé sur plusieurs missions puis je
finissais avec nous c'est comme les gens
se spécialisent dans différentes
émissions moi je me suis spécialiste
plus comme une fois que la mission est
comme l'idée la mission est développée
j'aime se construire des choses
construit test le début des opérations
je travaillais sur une mission qui
s'appelait inside comme je l'ai dit puis
d'enfant chercher nous on change de job
à l'interne puis je vais se poser
travailler sur quelque chose d'autre
puis la personne avec qui je travaillais
sur le projet que j'étais était comment
veux-tu venir travailler sur Mars 20
place pour moi c'était vraiment toute
seule
ils avaient besoin de quelqu'un pour
aider dans le système de navigation de
surface pour pour le robot lui-même je
me souviens d'entrevue parce que mes
amis maintenant mec puis j'arrive dans
son bureau est-ce une journée pluvieuse
il y avait un bureau comme tout fermé je
me souviens encore
c'est pas tu peux pas c'est pas
n'importe qui qui peut aller porter son
CV pour appliquer
à la main j'imagine je pense pas que je
peux aller poser mon CDI
la maison on a des artistes qui
travaillent pour nous des gens
communications
[Rires]
de tête qui qui mettons qui travaillent
pour la NASA qui spa du monde qui vont
les voir puis qu'ils disent attendus de
venir ou bien c'est comme
les gens qui ont ces aptitudes-là
appelaient qu'habituellement
il doit en avoir je sais pas honnêtement
c'est quand même très petit ça a l'air
grand le monde presque tout soutien tu
te rends compte quelqu'un qui travaille
dans la spatiale aux États-Unis c'est
sûr qu'on a quelqu'un qu'on connaît en
commun avec quand on a surtout quand
c'est plus un contraire quand les gens
cherchent une job où ils veulent partir
de où est-ce qu'ils sont ben le
ton va le savoir
mais c'est sûr que si je vais super avec
des amis qui travaillent ailleurs ils
vont être
mais c'est pas c'est pas comme un
chasseur de tête corporate c'est plus
comme parce qu'on connaît tous il faut
faire attention parce qu'on se connaît
de ça
maintenant pour toi la semaine avant
l'atterrissage sur Mars puis la journée
même ça ressemble à quoi en même temps
non il y a pas de nuit de sommeil il y a
pas de il y a des snacks parce que moi
je travaillais pas sur le système
d'atterrissage mais c'est comme le jour
après le jour de l'atterrissage c'est
parce que je travaille sur les
opérations de surface et c'est nous qui
de fallait que tu sois prêt à faire les
opérations avec nous on a lancé avec mon
système de barbec qui fonctionne mais on
avait encore toutes sortes de test pour
se préparer pour faire les opérations
sur la surface de Mars et que ça a été
comme les 7 mois qu'on est allé vers
mars c'était vraiment super occupé mais
je me souviens plus la semaine
exactement ce qu'on a fait je pense
qu'ils nous ont donné quand même
quelques jours de congés comme pour nous
préparer parce qu'on allait entrer nous
autres une période très très occupée
l'enfant puis mais le jour même c'est
une longue journée parce que nous
fallait arriver avant l'atterrissage de
l'équipe d'atterrissage c'est
l'atterrissage j'étais à 11h moi j'étais
levé depuis 5h du matin j'ai pas dû
dormir il faut que tu sois là quelques
heures à l'avance là l'atterrissage se
passe chez nous après ça nous donne les
clés de la voiture enfant de nous
fallait qu'on fasse nos tests pour être
sûr que tout s'est bien passé dans le
fond
comment pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut lui
parler demain matin mais le moment de
l'atterrissage de c'est quoi l'ambiance
comment
ça oh tout le monde est là regardez les
données
quand tu dis tu peux rien faire tu es
comme ok
comme c'est quoi ça mais une ligne de
code qui passe
pourquoi c'est jaune ça ok mais c'est
fait que dès qu'on avait comme il y a
juste certaines personnes qui avaient
droit de parler sur le c'est comme on a
un système de communication et que
jusqu'à certaines personnes qui avaient
le droit de communiquer certaines choses
c'était comme toute pré planifié c'est
comment qui toi quand tu vois ça tu dis
ça quand tu vois ça tu dis ça fait que
ouais je suis vraiment stressant on
disposait assis là tu t'es exposé parce
que tu avais des caméras tu le monde
entier te regarde tu sais quel pire
c'est que le monde entier te regarde
j'étais pas capable d'être assise mais
comme deux trois fois
en plus c'est encore la covid ça fait
qu'on était pas supposé être proche de
chacun mais moi j'étais comme je suis
pas capable
c'est sûr comme dans tout bon film de
petit science-fiction mais de d'espace
parce que tout le monde est arrivé sur
son écran puis là au moment où est-ce
que ça réussi
que tu comprennes que ça a pris 10 ans
qu'on serait sur
les 7 dernières minutes de
l'atterrissage c'est les plus stressante
fait que oui on est content quand ça va
sept minutes sachant que justement les
les tentatives passées souvent
même
préparé justement pour pouvoir recréer
des données mais les
on va faire une autre projet
récemment mais
la mission la plus récente qui échouée
c'était pas vraiment échoué mais il y a
eu je me souviens quand j'avais commencé
au Japan il y avait un petit projet qui
était comme à être lancé sur une
physique comme expérimentale puisse avec
exploser au lancement mettez c'est
tellement sérieux quand les choses comme
ça se passe que il y avait comme ça des
psychologues au travail il y avait la
thérapie de groupe c'est parce que c'est
quand ça fait des années peut-être
imagine tu sais moi j'adresse 12 ans 25
ans mais si ça fait cinq six ans là que
toute ta carrière là-dessus
dans ta vie là c'est comme un deuil en
plus en même temps sûrement c'est comme
faire un film que jamais personne va le
voir
personne qui peut savoir
afin de
ton travail de cinq ans c'est marqué
échec où il doit avoir
prouvé
[Musique]
pas mais je pense qu'on est tous préparé
que ça va nous arriver au moins une fois
dans notre carrière parce que c'était
pas des chèques ça veut dire que tu
essayes pas assez non
c'est ça qui va en avoir des échecs
parce que
moi j'en ai pas eu dans ma carrière
encore des gros comme ça mais c'est sûr
qu'il va se passer quelque chose d'un
jour
c'est comme si tu subis jamais d'essai
d'échec c'est peut-être que tu essaies
jamais assez quelque chose d'assez
ambitieux c'est comme quand je fais du
ski si je tombe pas dans la journée ça
veut dire que j'ai passé
c'est vrai
fac le robot
la délivrance ultime mais en même temps
c'est le début
le début du vrai travail
le but c'est quel genre de données qu'on
voulait recueillir
c'est que ça va en fait prendre des
échantillons qu'on va ramener vers la
terre éventuellement parce que le but de
la mission c'est de d'étudier est-ce
qu'il y aurait pu avoir de la vie sur
Mars ce qui est intéressant avec ça
c'est que la première fois qu'on a
atterrit sur Mars avec Viking dans les
années 70 c'était le but de cette
mission là est-ce que James mais il faut
que tu imagines que dans les années 70
les gens pensaient vraiment qu'il y
avait de la vie sur Mars tellement que
sur Viking ce sont les ingénieurs et
scientifiques ce sont demandés s'il
devrait acheter une lumière sur
l'atterrissage parce que si la vie
martienne est une vie nocturne comment
on va pouvoir l'avoir c'était vraiment
ça
bouclier pour se défendre
mais
il s'imaginait que ça serait plus facile
d'enfants
déchiré la communauté scientifique parce
que il y avait des données que les gens
étaient comme postures les gens qui
disent oui oui ça ça prouve qu'il y a de
la vie et puis d'autres qui disait non
puis encore à ce jour il y a des gens
qui sont comme ah peut-être que les
données de Viking fait ce qui s'est
passé après avoir King c'est que son
retour mais ça a pris quand même tout le
temps pour qu'on a un autre attrait ça
après ça c'était parfait
il y a eu des essais entre qui ont pas
fonctionné
mais elle est son revenues à ok est-ce
que c'est quoi l'histoire de mars est-ce
que l'eau
spirity ont montré qu'il y avait eu de
l'eau après on a eu curiosité qui a
montré que ah oui mars avaient un
environnement habitable il y a des
millions d'années ressemblait à la terre
avec quoi on est revenu à la question ok
il y avait de l'eau c'est un
environnement habitable dans le temps où
il y avait de la au début de vie sur
Terre ce qui aurait pu avoir de la vie
sur Mars mais pour répondre à cette
question là on sait maintenant que tu
peux pas amener juste deux trois
instruments puis aller faire ça se fait
que ramener les instruments les
échantillons sur terre c'est ça qui va
nous permettre vraiment évaluer ça puis
on a enterré dans le cratère de G0 qui
est un cratère c'est un cratère qui qui
est un ancien lac puis il y avait une
rivière qui alimentait cela clope et qui
ressortait l'autre bord fait que s'il y
avait eu de la vie sur Mars ça serait
peut-être là et puis un delta de la
rivière qui était bon les détails c'est
sur de la terre c'est très très fertile
et c'est là que le robot se dirige vers
là pour prendre des échantillons
on dit ça ressemblait à la terre ça
ressemblait à la terre ça c'est le 3
milliards
ça ressemble à la tasse et qu'il y avait
tous ces petits
on sait c'est qu'il y avait de l'eau
liquide le type
c'est le début de la vie mais tu sais
quand on dit que c'était début de la vie
c'était comme c'était de la vie comme
micro biologique c'était quelques
quelques
à quelle vitesse va le robot
il s'est rendu dans l'état parce que là
l'année passée on fait une campagne de
conduite le fait que ça c'est pas dessus
parce que ça peut convaincreduire
400 gras par jour au fait que tu peux
faire quelques kilomètres par jour avec
plus qu'une dizaine de kilomètres j'ai
pas regardé récemment combien on a fait
mais qui s'est déjà rendu vers le delta
plus ça va monter sur le delta
éventuellement
c'est le robot le plus rapide qu'on n'a
jamais atterri mais c'est quand même là
mais puisqu'on dur lui-même c'est qu'une
fun c'est que bon il y a pas de route
sur Mars
mais mais il peut regarder comme ok il y
a des roches là fait que je passe entre
les deux ou je vais passer autour par
dessus avec ça ça nous aide beaucoup
parce que quand tu as pas ce système de
conduite là mais tu peux seulement
conduire aussi loin que ce que tu peux
nous c'est pas comme si on conduit avec
un joystick à la maison
à chaque soir martien on reçoit des
données de mars on en avait ça puis on
planifie la journée d'après avec si tu
conduis sans qu'il y a un système de
conduite de bord mais tu peux seulement
regarder ce que tu vois dans les dans
les photos puis dire ok mais on va aller
on va prendre ce chemin là puis on va
s'arrêter prendre autre photo puis
demain matin que le robot peut faire
absolument
assez longtemps puis le robot dans le
fait encore actif là toi tu es sur un
autre dossier mais lui il continue puis
il va continuer encore combien de temps
il va prendre le bus c'est de prendre
une trentaine d'échantillons en ramené
une partie de ça mais c'est comme
curiosité qui atterrit en 2012 c'était
une mission en principe la mission de
base est une mission de 2 ans mais ça
fait 10 ans puis on l'a pas encore à
tous les jours il va ramener
physiquement c'est pas sa mission là qui
va ramener les échantillons on va en
amener envoyer notre fait qu'on veut
envoyer une autre mission qui va aller
chercher les échantillons les mettre
dans une fusée les ramener vers la terre
on n'a jamais fait de ça revenir de mars
la première fois ça n'a jamais lancé
d'un autre d'un autre d'une autre
planète
de ramener des produits des virus
martiens
un domaine encore là d'ingénierie pour
des gens en équipe qui font qui
s'appelle la protection de la planète ça
va être dans les deux sens fait que nous
par exemple quand on va sur Mars pour
faire attention de parler des bactéries
avec nous
c'est tellement intéressant
on fait que d'un bar on fait on amène
rien de nous sur mars parce que
premièrement c'est pas notre planète
c'est que c'est pas un outil c'est fou
qu'on la garde propre quand même s'il y
a de la vie c'est pas amener un virus
dans dans l'autre sens aussi c'est que
puis aussi si tu veux pas amener des
bactéries terriennes plus tu trouves la
vie tu es comme est-ce que on amené avec
nous ou est-ce que c'était
une vie qui ressemble à l'anneau
elle est vraiment partout hein
puis dans l'autre sens c'est que oui les
échantillons qui reviennent et ils vont
être atterri puis là on va avoir mieux
il y a des ingénieurs qui travaillent
là-dessus c'est comme la place ça va
être atterri mais aussi comme le
bâtiment où on va amener ça transférer
mes tubes pour que ça soit tout super
bien isolé au moins au début c'est sûr
qu'on dit c'est même bizarre qu'on
pensait mais tu imagines quand les les
astronautes sont allés sur la Lune en
1969 ben on les a mis en 40e quand
quarantaine quand on revenus parce qu'on
s'inquiétait vraiment qu'il aurait pu
avoir la vie sur la Lune avec elle donc
on sait pas on fait attention
ouais parce que tous les
tous les bons films de science-fiction
horreur comme on se demande c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui va dans l'espace qui
ramène quelque chose
là mais c'est un parasite qui qui tue
tout le monde là
puis
dans le fond le titre dans les données
que
le robot recueilli
mettons avant d'envoyer ce robot là puis
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on a avancé dans notre
compréhension de base qui nous a permis
de
déjà dans quelques mois dans quelques
années oui parce que en fait
le robot en plus de ces échantillons là
bon il y a des instruments de bord fait
que ça nous permet d'étudier le climat
on a confirmé par exemple le fait que le
carter de G0 c'est qu'on s'imaginait que
c'est un lac avant c'était une potence
mais on était jamais allé fait qu'on a
pas qu'on avait pas pu confirmé mais là
ils ont confirmés que oui ils ont été
l'ancienne environnement des roches
mécaniques ça fait qu'on comprend
beaucoup plus environnement de mars on
est aussi un hélicoptère avec nous avec
du côté d'ingénierie de se faire voler
en hélicoptère sur Mars que c'est c'est
on en a pris beaucoup beaucoup sur
l'atmosphère martien qu'est-ce que ça
prend pour faire voler des hélicoptères
sur Mars ça fait que YouTube de
découvertes scientifiques comme ça qui
sont passés qui qui vont continuer à
sortir dans les prochaines années ça
prend du temps analyser les données
c'est long
puis c'est surtout écrit les papiers
scientifiques puis après ça à voir les
corrections de papier
je comprends pas la phrase numéro 3
la
gravité sur Mars
comprendre ça j'imagine oui mais c'est
ça mais dans le fond c'est un tiers la
gravité mais l'atmosphère de 100% de
l'atmosphère fait que c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de voler sur Mars que sur
terre parce que ici sur tablette
mais pour nous ce qui était difficile
sur Mars non seulement ça pour faire
voler mais aussi le climat comme un peu
bizarre comme il y a des vents
l'après-midi tout dépend où est-ce que
tu es puis aussi il faut que tu
souhaites automatiser parce que
justement toi tu peux pas c'est pas
comme ton jaune à la maison que tu peux
voir petit ok
fallait qu'on automatise toutes à
l'avance une journée à l'avance fait que
rendu l'autre si le vin est trop haut
ben on peut pas planifier tout ça fait
que ça fait ça faisait un peu peur au
début ça s'est bien passé combien de
temps les commandes c'est les commandes
prennent combien de temps à se rendre ça
dépend du temps de l'année mais c'est
comme entre 7 et 15 ça peut être jusqu'à
20 minutes
c'est rapide qu'une commande
parce que mais c'est pour ça genre que
on fait pas ça en temps réel parce que
disons autant de l'année c'est 10
minutes ça veut dire que tu envoies une
commande 10 minutes ça fait quelque
chose ça revient 10 minutes c'est long
avec on fait c'est pour ça qu'on fait ça
une fois par jour mais j'imagine que tu
es
relatifs mais ça va la vitesse de la
lumière ça veut dire que quand tu gagnes
quand tu regardes mars dans le ciel
comme là
en début décembre ça va être
l'opposition demain ça veut dire que
c'est le temps de l'année où ben c'est
la journée où
le Soleil la Terre et Mars ont une ligne
avec la terre entre Mars et le soleil
c'est aussi le temps d'année ou presque
que Mars est le plus proche à la terre
plus à peu près 7 minutes pour ça pour
la vitesse de la lumière mais ça veut
dire que
en début décembre mais ça veut dire que
tu le vois 7 minutes dans le passé la
même chose le soleil c'est à peu près 11
minutes dans le passé
avec la radio
c'est faux
faites le soleil c'est 10 minutes à peu
près
loin mais vraiment plus proche que les
autres les autres étoiles
c'est à quelques années de lumière ça
veut dire que tu vois dans le passé
on parlait des télescopes tantôt mais
c'est comme ça que tu vois dans le passé
c'est parce que tu regardes de la
lumière qui est vraiment pris tu sais
c'est de la lumière qui vient d'arriver
dans le télescope physiquement parce que
ça arrive
physiquement c'est une lumière mais ça
veut dire que cette lumière là le
stimagine c'est ça qui me demande la
tête quand je pense elle le voyageait
depuis le début du big bang pour arriver
dans dans ta lentille
vraiment loin on peut voir c'est ça que
James
c'est toujours comme c'est ça déjà des
fois les gens j'ai un ami qu'une seule
enduit c'est comme il y avait une
nouvelle photo de de James web qui avait
été
qui est sorti c'est le pilote c'est
comme c'est très très connu c'est comme
c'est de c'est quoi le mot c'est c'est
de la poussière c'était le début d'une
d'une étoile c'est de la poussière puis
il me dit ouais mais c'est gros comment
c'est est-ce que c'est gros comme les
États-Unis c'est comme dans la terre et
petite copine
locataire c'est ça
plus tu t'imagines aussi que c'est s'il
y a des millions d'années en arrière
déjà ça leur demande
il y a des gens que je connais que ça
sent pas bien quand tu penses à ça parce
que ton ta pensée humaine peut pas
penser à quelque chose de SIO si grand
comme ça c'est une photo
puis c'est tout seul
c'est fou puis
l'autre affaire qui me rend qui me crée
de l'anxiété inverse c'est que si
mettons quand on dit que on
aussi loin dans nous que en haut dans le
fond là
c'est
quoi la la position et la position
je peux chercher le bon mot là mais
c'est quoi la position à la NASA sur la
vie à l'extérieur de la terre mais on
aucune idée
je pense qu'on espère on espère qu'il y
en aide mais Mathis c'est sûr que c'est
intéressant d'abord ou de l'autre ça
serait vraiment plate on était seul mais
que ce soit la seule place où est-ce que
vraiment prouver comment la vie a
commencé sur terre mais c'est presque
impossible à prouver dans ce sens là
mais c'est sûr on est allé sur Mars pour
chercher des échantillons pour voir s'il
y a eu la vie sur Mars on va vers la
lune d'Europe pour voir si est-ce que
est-ce qu'il pourrait avoir la villa où
il y aurait pu en avoir on étudie les
exoplanètes qui sont les planètes autour
d'autres soleils pour voir si elles sont
habitables ou s'il y a des signes de vie
des signes peut-être à ce qu'il y a un
cycle de carbone ou quoi que quelque
chose qu'on peut voir dans l'atmosphère
qui nous donne une idée de ce qui est-ce
qui pourrait avoir quelque chose qui se
passe là et que c'est à quand tu
regardes comme il y a tout un domaine
qui s'appelle l'astro biologie qui est
vraiment social étude de la vie ailleurs
à l'extérieur de la terre donc c'est
je pense que avec tout ce qu'on fait en
ce moment c'est entre la vie dans notre
système solaire ou s'il y a eu dans
notre système solaire on risque de le
savoir pendant notre vie à nous à
l'extérieur du système solaire c'est
plus difficile parce que
voyagez-le on peut juste observer c'est
avec quelque chose comme James webs ça
se peut que mais c'est très très
difficile de prouver que de la vie juste
en observant comme ça
puis mais comme on peut pas y aller en
ce moment ça prendrait comme ça prendra
un grand avancement technologique mais
juste le fait de mettons qu'on découvre
qu'il y a eu de la vie sur Mars mais le
titre mettons là on a un exemple
quoi je veux dire c'est mais si on
découvre que la peine la voisine aussi
de la Bible tout d'un coup on peut faire
le guest qui il y en a partout
mathématicien mais c'est des fois il
mais l'écologie de Drake pas Drake vous
connaissez c'est support à zéro plus 100
tu es rendu à 100 real quick ça c'est
l'équation de Drake mais les voisins en
fait c'est une occasion qui donne la
probabilité de rencontrer de rencontrer
nos civilisation intelligente mais en
fait ce que ça dit quand est-ce que ça
dit ok combien de combien de galaxies
dans l'hiver combien de système solaire
que là dedans combien de planètes mais
comme la seule chose en cette équation
là qu'on comprend pas qu'on n'a pas le
chiffre c'est combien de planètes pas
juste qu'ils sont invités mais combien
de planètes ont de la vie ça fait que
mais l'enfant c'est que même si on dit
que juste
satisfaitement d'enfonce si tu y penses
vraiment c'est que oui si si juste une
planète où on trouve la vie ça veut dire
qu'il y en a partout parce que parce que
dans le fond là on sait à ce moment-là
qu'on n'est pas unique mais pour le
moment on peut pas pour le moment tant
qu'on pense maintenant qu'on a pas
prouvé qu'on n'est pas unique on peut
parler un peu plus
étoiles
mettez c'est sûr que les civilisations
la durée d'une civilisation comme la
durée de la civilisation humaine
comparée à la vie d'une planète ou la
vie d'une étoile c'est tout petit tout
petit ok oui mais si elle l'a vu tu as
des milliards d'années ou même plus que
ça là après mon satisfaitement trouvé
c'est comme être capable de trouver
quelqu'un que tu peux communiquer avec
dans avant que notre civilisation soit
finie soit vraiment là que notre
civilisation meurt c'est presque
impossible
peut-être que c'est plus une question
philosophique mais la mort la
civilisation et
on peut pas l'éviter
on sait pas
mais c'est ce qu'un jour de la planète
va mourir mais c'est bon je pense que
les gens disent ok si on est une
civilisation qui peut quitter mais
encore là il nous manque la technologie
mais qui peut quitter notre planète
peut-être que c'est au moins un peu plus
intelligent pour s'occuper de Nathalie
notre plus vite à la qu'est-ce qu'on va
mais
c'est pour ça que éventuellement tu es
dans les sims de science-fiction souvent
c'est ça qu'on trouve c'est que les gens
c'est l'annexe la prochaine chose à
penser c'est ok ben là si on parle notre
terre où est-ce qu'on s'en va est-ce
qu'on peut aller sur une autre planète
dans un autre système solaire c'est
comme ça que la vie survivrait mais on
n'est pas on n'est pas rendu à quoi ça
ressemble tu parlais des exoplanètes là
à quoi ça ressemble l'étude des
exoplanètes en ce moment puis mettons
que ça prend que ça prendrait pour
propulser ses recherches là plus loin à
cause de c'est vraiment ça va être parce
que James Web peut
prendre des images bah on en a vu déjà
des images directes des exoplanètes en
ce moment
des centaines de milliers de qui ont été
vu ce qui est intéressant c'est que
c'est moi je suis né dans les années 80
quand je suis né on avait jamais vu une
autre planète à l'extérieur notre
système solaire on a étudié dans ta tête
ok oui devant l'avoir mais on en avait
jamais vu je pense la première c'est des
confirmer c'était au début des années 90
parce qu'il l'avait fait par les
différentes manières de voir des
exoplanètes donc une c'est l'imagerie
directe mais c'est genre moins de 5% des
experts qu'on a vu qu'on a détecté comme
ça et un autre que tu peux regarder
l'étoile plus tu peux voir l'ombre de la
planète passer devant et que ça peut
donner quelque chose
il y a aussi comme tu peux regarder
l'orbite des étoiles puis tu sais comme
nous en orbite autour d'une étoile mais
notre masse mais ça fait bouger l'étoile
un tout petit peu fait que il aussi puis
aussi la forme de l'espace dans le fond
de la gravitation qui peut passer aux
autres manières de voir les exoplanètes
la méthode de transition est une des
plus populaires en ce moment mais pour
une méthode de tradition faut que tu
faut que tu ne vois plus qu'une fois un
enfant pour vraiment savoir leur but la
grandeur de
ça prend du temps on a vu beaucoup mais
aussi c'est quand même avec la méthode
de transition tu peux dire ok la lumière
qu'on voit du soleil va changer un peu
tout dépendant de la composition
de la planète mais tu peux pas beaucoup
étudier la planète de cette manière-là
donc là avec James web ça va être super
intéressant parce qu'ils sont capables
non seulement de prendre des images
directes de la planète mais aussi
d'avoir une région qui nous permet de
voir l'atmosphère par exemple parce que
l'atmosphère disons que tu as une
planète rocheuse comme la terre
l'atmosphère est toute petite
compaorisateur mais qui étudier ça c'est
super difficile mais jenzo est capable
de faire ça et puis je pense que en
étant capable de voir l'atmosphère
puis je pense que c'est à faire de
couleur là dedans on est capable de
savoir la composition donc mettons si de
l'oxygène comme excitant parce que
c'est ça qui va se paraître intéressant
mais moi je pensais 5 10 prochaines
années on va voir par exemple une
planète qui dans bonne distance de
l'étoile pour être ça bonne température
puis que là il y a une composition
d'oxygène qui ressemble à la nôtre c'est
excitant des candidats par exemple qui
sont dans la botte qui s'appelle la zone
de Boucle d'or c'est la zone habitable
dans un système solaire fait que nous
par exemple dans dans notre système
solaire la zone de Boucle d'Or commence
juste après Vénus puis aux environs de
mars fait ça c'est entre Vénus
à partir du soleil
puis en fait c'est la définition de la
zone de brûleur encore là parce qu'on
connaît juste notre vie à nous nous on
se dit qu'on a besoin d'eau liquide pour
vivre fait que c'est la zone dans ce
système solaire où tu pourrais avoir de
l'eau liquide tout dépendant des
conditions de la planète on s'entend que
ni mars ni Vénus sont habitables en ce
moment mais il serait sur la barre de
cette zone là puis nous on est dedans et
qu'on regarde autour de d'autres étoiles
de dépendant de la grosseur de l'étoile
ou est-ce que la zone de prépa serait
puis est-ce que des planètes là est-ce
que des planètes rocheuses donc ça ça a
été fait déjà comme il y avait le
système trappiste par exemple quelques
années vous êtes peut-être entendu
cependant la nouvelle mais que avec le
système trappiste pour mettre James web
va essayer de prendre des images de ces
de ces planètes là parce que c'est des
planètes super intéressantes qui
pourraient peut-être avoir de la vie
[Musique]
par rapport on parlait des civilisations
c'est j'avais entendu que tu mettes nous
notification en ce moment on laisse
quand même une trace parce qu'on aimait
des ondes dans l'espace qui qui continue
de voyager le dit donc on envoie même
des messages dans l'espace
avec cette toilette c'était au début
[Rires]
est-ce que c'est curieux mettons pour
vous que partout où est-ce que les
autres on écoute on regarde on détecte
jamais ça même si c'est pas c'est nous
si on écoute mais c'est ça que c'est pas
nous quand nous c'est une organisation
c'est comme ça qui fait ça qui envoie
des ondes justement
puis des fois ils disent entendent
quelque chose mais c'est souvent c'est
rien mais encore là parce que quand tu
penses à la longueur de l'humanité et
combien de temps ça aurait pu prendre
ces choses-là d'arriver c'est pas la
même échelle c'est pas curieux nous
notre vie est tellement petite que ça se
peut que ça soit là puis que ça c'est
juste pas arrivé encore
on n'est pas entendu qu'on n'écoute pas
c'est aussi que quand on parle de la
recherche de la vie en tant qu'humain on
n'est pas si intelligent que ça on sait
pas on sait pas c'est quoi la grandeur
de l'intelligence
c'est nous on comprend la vie d'une
certaine manière mais peut-être qu'on
est bien épais qu'on la voit pas parce
qu'on comprend pas parce que c'est
quelque chose de complètement différent
la vie de ce qu'on s'imagine c'est
peut-être que les gens nous regardent
qu'on est des fourmis pour les autres
entendu qu'il disait quelque chose de
même disait peut-être que déjà des des
entités qui sont venus ici à la
recherche devient intelligente parce que
on peut trouver
civilisation intelligente tu arrives ici
en fait non non
on on utilise la vie c'est à base de
carbone ça fait que on utilise la vie
comme nous à force de carbone qui a de
l'eau ça fait que si on étudie comme qui
on pense que ça prend des mannequin
d'organes ça prend d'énergie mais est-ce
que c'est juste ça la vie peut-être que
non avec c'est il y a ça aussi tu sais
que c'est comme on étudie comme là on
était d'écouter des ondes de Radio oui
mais est-ce que c'est comme ça que
non c'est ça on peut même pas imaginer
probablement comment c'est quoi la vie
ailleurs ça peut être complètement autre
chose aussi c'est faux puis mettons je
te repose un peu la question de pH à
poser tantôt mais tu mets ton par
rapport à mars
est-ce que vous êtes complètement in the
dark ou bien mettons vous avez
est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
évalué les probabilités d'en trouver la
vie où vous avez vraiment complètement
ça prend c'est quoi qui commence la vie
c'est ça le problème c'est que si on
savait comme si dans un laboratoire je
pouvais dire escapade de créer de la vie
demain matin qui était qu'on a trouvé
les ingrédients mais à ce moment-là ça
aurait été plus facile de mettre une
probabilité sur OK mais c'est ça les
ingrédients il faut quand même n'importe
quoi donc il faut un éclair pour
commencer de la vie c'est parce que tu
as besoin d'un choc d'énergie mais là
statiquement tu pourrais dire ok
probabilité qu'il y avait de la météo
sur Mars des éclairs ok c'est ça la
probabilité qu'on trouve la vie et
contre la trouve mais comme on sait pas
ben tu peux pas mettre on se dit oui il
y a des bonnes chances il y avait de
l'eau il y avait de l'énergie ça
ressemble à la terre si la terre est
mars se ressemblait en même temps
il y a même des gens qui croient que la
vie aurait pu venir de Mars cette
semaine si vous connaissez
la compagnie qui a fondé ben par
beaucoup de ça dans son éducation mais
tu essayes les gens qui croient que elle
a vu que peut-être on aurait pu
commencer sur Mars puis est arrivé sur
Terre avec une météorite quelque chose
venir
qui envoie une roche sur l'autre il y
avait des organismes
d'ailleurs qui est enterrée qui aura
atterri sur terre
tu peux pas satisfa mettre un homme un
chiffre mais bon
ça serait vraiment bizarre s'il y en
avait pas
en passant justement pas mieux je pense
que c'est
sachant que ça arrive ce mettons que des
bouts de terre qui sont envoyés dans
l'espace puis qui atterrissent à
différents endroits comme sur Mars
tout mourrait mais non mais même la
Station spatiale internationale on a
trouvé des choses qui survivent à
l'extérieur c'est avec
c'est très possible qu'il y ait une
comète avec la glace qui est quelque
chose aurait pu survivre puis atterrir
il est probabilité qu'il y a du de quoi
mettons mettons on sait qu'il a vu ici
on sait que de temps en temps il y a des
débris qui vont aller sur Mars on peut
se dire peut-être qu'on a amené quelque
chose là-bas moi parce que tu sais pas
comme si c'est pas comme si des débris
partent de la terre c'était pendant la
formation de la Terre on pense pas qu'il
y avait de la vie dans ce temps-là avec
ses pas c'est pas nécessairement comme
ça c'est ça le problème c'est que
c'est des matériaux c'est comme au début
de la formation du système solaire il y
avait plein de roches partout ça c'est
ça a formé des planètes c'est là que
peut-être un échange de matériel mais
plus maintenant
puis est-ce qu'on sait
la composition atmosphère non pas
vraiment avec on sait ce qu'il y a dans
l'atmosphère maintenant c'est beaucoup
de dioxyde de carbone mais on sait pas
exactement ce système est toujours juste
de carbone aussi il y avait eu autre
chose ça dépend un peu aussi s'il y
avait de la vie peut-être que ça changer
c'est ce que ça sert toujours été du
diable de carbone c'est sûr que tu peux
sûrement limiter ce qui aurait pu avoir
ma sœur en te basant sur le genre de
molécule qu'on retrouve puisqu'on
retrouve dans les roches les choses
comme ça mais maintenant on sait pas
exactement puis qu'est-ce que fait que
des changements climatiques de même
sûrement mais c'est une autre chose
qu'on étudie mais il y a une hypothèse
avec enfants mais c'est la mission
inside un peu étudier ça fait ce qui est
intéressant avec la planète Mars c'est
que
tu es sur Terre on a un noyau externe
interne un manteau puis une croûte puis
sur terre la raison pourquoi on a notre
champ magnétique c'est parce qu'on a un
noyau qui est du métal qui se refroidit
puis on se refroidissant sa bouche puis
quand le métal ça bouge mais ça craint
un champ magnétique puis sur terre c'est
ça qui protège un atmosphère parce que
le vent et bien avant solaire avec le
soleil était imagine toujours que
l'espace est vide mais c'est vraiment
pas vide il y a un vent qui vient
toujours du soleil et que si tu regardes
ça rappelle peut-être à l'école tu as
peut-être vu seul champ magnétique puis
il y a comme une queue en arrière du
champ magnétique quand tu vois des
photos de ben c'est pas des photos de
champ magnétique de la Terre mais c'est
comme une reproduction mais dans le fond
ça c'est le vent qui souffle notre champ
magnétique protège notre atmosphère fait
que sur Mars l'hypothèse et que il y
aurait peut-être il y avait peut-être eu
un noyau comme ça qui s'est refroidi
beaucoup plus rapidement mars est plus
petite mais peut-être que des mécanismes
aussi qui avaient été différents pendant
la formation de cette planète là donc il
y aurait peut-être on sait qu'il y a eu
un champ magnétique global qui
n'existait plus parce qu'il y a encore
des restants de champ magnétiques comme
on a amené des magnétomètre avec nous
sur Mars
et donc ce champ magnétique là aurait
protégé l'atmosphère et quand la théorie
qui quand le noyau ce serait refroidi
qu'on aurait perdu ce champ magnétique
là et éventuellement le vent du soleil
comme c'est pas parti dans l'espace donc
elle est partie aussi oui mais il y en a
encore de l'eau sur mer mais c'est sous
forme de glace en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que si tu regardes mars comme
quand c'est l'hiver dans l'atmosphère
dans la l'hémisphère Nord il y a une
calotte de glace en haut
puis quand les saisons changent en fait
le problème sur Mars c'est que la
pression et la température sont trop
basses pour qu'il y a de l'eau liquide
c'est peut-être la chimie de secondaire
4 5 mais on avait je me souviens de ça
parce que c'était comme les petits
diagrammes ça dit OK
à cette température parce que tu sais on
dit l'eau bout à 100 degrés Celsius qui
gère la zéro mais pas c'est juste à zéro
atmosphère c'est à au niveau de la mer
comme le suivant montage
disons que tu étais à 10000 pieds mais
l'eau elle bouge pas ça là elle boit 90
parce que parce que la pression a
beaucoup plus basse c'est que donc je
continue continue comme ça tu te
retrouves sur Mars que tu dis ok là dans
le fond toutes ces les phases d'un de
l'eau par exemple sont définis par la
température et la pression donc c'est un
c'est un diagramme que tu peux utiliser
mais sur Mars il fait froid et la
pression est très très basse avec la
pression l'eau ne peut pas exister en
forme liquide sur leur système là vendo
sur Mars soit que ça gèlerai ou que ça
sublimerait ça resterait pas liquide
avec ce qui se passe tu t'en fous pour
le nord de mars disons quand l'été
arrive c'est que la glace la glace part
directement de glace en gaz
exactement ça ça peut pas ça peut pas
exister en forme de directement c'est
fou puis il fait combien sur Mars
j'en ai chaude c'est moins 40
il y a des été automne-hiver une année
martienne c'est deux ans avec sa dépense
ça dépend un peu de
quand il fait chaud puis un peu comme
tantôt quand tu me dis ça prend 7
minutes pour que le message se rendement
[Rires]
planer de comme on va aller coloniser
mars ça va être vraiment trop aride pour
qu'on puisse pour que ça puisse être la
solution permanente à comme je
m'imaginerai que tu es on pourrait aller
envoyer des bas scientifiques des gens
qui vivent là pour quelques années ou
qui reviennent sur terre après mettez
premièrement la gravité comment ça va
affecter le corps humain mais je
comprends pas en fond c'est pourquoi que
les aimants sont une belle planète ici
c'est pas un plan B mars
c'est sûr que ça serait super
intéressant d'aller l'étudier de voir si
on peut vivre ailleurs de montrer que tu
es de démontrer que en tant que
civilisation on peut s'établir ailleurs
mais mais là de dire qu'on va aller
vivre là-bas
la philosophie c'est plus de dire s'il
arrive de quoi un catac x ici mettons
une comète qui frappe la Terre mais il y
a de la vie ailleurs il y a de
l'humanité ailleurs qui fait que ce qui
fait que les pas complètement éteint je
pense que c'est un peu ça
tu peux vraiment soutenir la vie sur
Mars c'est ça aussi
ça serait typiquement on dirait que ça
fait des années qui dit ah non on y va
dans deux ans là on part en mars c'est
comme si finalement évidemment ça ça
arrive pas
occupé par autre chose
ça fait combien de temps
[Musique]
bref c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a
visage
je pense que l'idée d'avoir une base
scientifique permanente sur Mars oui
peut-être que tu sais c'est comme là on
a une partie scientifique permanence
dans l'espace c'est fait que oui je
pense que c'est possible qu'on
envisageait dans les 100 prochaines
années peut-être mais de dire que
je pense parce qu'on dirait moi ou c'est
proche
oui très très vite parce que je me dis
mettons toutes va tellement
exponentiellement vite c'est dans Ça
c'est sûr que peut-être que je suis une
pessimiste c'est sûr que le monde a
tellement changé dans les 20 30
prochaines années c'est difficile métier
de dire qu'on va envoyer des humains sur
Mars moi ça m'étonnerait que ça soit
avant 2040 je sais que ma comme la NASA
puis ça c'est vraiment très personnel
c'est juste la manière que je vois le
mon évoluer puis le nom de notre travail
qu'on a à faire mais c'est de la chaîne
nous dit qu'on allait en 2030 les
États-Unis direct ils ont en 2030 mais
bon son 2039 c'est encore en 2030 mais
mettez-le là on est quoi 20 deux je
pense qu'on va retourner les humains sur
la lune si 2024 2025 à peu près c'est
pour ça j'y crois parce que là avec
surtout avec Artémis que l'on lancé puis
on a déjà fait conseil à peu près
comment le faire tu travailles à faire
encore
mais c'est une grosse différence de dire
entre aller sur la Lune aller sur Mars
c'est pas la même chose du tout
et déjà comme ramener des échantillons
de persévérance ça va être au début des
années 2030 parce que ça prend juste
tant tant que ça développer tout ça on
n'a pas commencé à développer tous les
systèmes d'atterrissage humain sur Mars
ça va prendre un peu de temps
s'il y a des avancements technologiques
très très rapide 2040 qu'on continue à
envoyer des gens tous les deux ans parce
que là un voyage sur Mars c'est pas 5
minutes non plus ça va prendre ça va te
prendre c'est cette motorante il faut
que tu restes là tu attends que les
planètes se réalisent pour pouvoir venir
tu sais que on s'entend qu'on s'attend à
peu près en voyage de deux ans deux ans
et demi quand on voit des humains on n'a
jamais envoyé un humain à l'extérieur si
longtemps que ça le plus longtemps c'est
à peu près un an quand ils vont se
passer spatiale et que tu travailles à
faire
deux ans et demi
est-ce que c'est assez pour rester en
forme et plus il se passe six mois dans
l'espace Paris
première
personne qui vont faire ça si jamais il
y a quelqu'un qui le fait
tu dis salut à tes tu dis salut à tes
proches avant de partir
mais c'est comme les premiers
astronautes qui sont partis c'était
vraiment comme ça c'est sûr que bon
c'est on va avoir des systèmes qu'on va
avoir bien essayé
qu'ils ont mais
c'est quoi toi dans ton dans ta
spécialité les avancées technologiques
que tu check le plus mettons que
c'est qui comme de quoi qui va débloquer
les ordinateurs de plus en plus
performants
il y avait l'ordinateur était moins bon
que ce que ton iPhone c'est
impressionnant vraiment moins bon là
vraiment moins bon le thé comme
l'hélicoptère qu'on a fait voler sur
Mars ben c'est la même ordinateur que tu
as dans un fixe à peu près ça c'est puis
déjà là il y avait deux ordinateurs à
bord c'est un des robots les plus
performants qu'on envoyait sur Mars donc
c'est fou à dire que avec ça ça on
avance mais c'est parce que tu peux pas
envoyer les mêmes ordinateurs parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de radiations dans
l'espace et sur Mars donc ça pas fait
affecter tes électroniques il faut que
ça soit quelque chose qui va durer mais
bien longtemps
au robot
[Rires]
c'est très intéressant c'est sûr que au
niveau tu es dans les 10 20 30
prochaines années ce qui serait
intéressant de voir c'est
tout ce qui est le voyage en Espagne
mais il y a pas rien que je peux dire ah
ça c'est vraiment prometteant que ça va
révolutionner mais c'est sûr qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de travail qui est
fait de la dent parce qu'en ce moment tu
sais on est limité à la vitesse de
laquelle on peut aller
est-ce que l'intelligence artificielle
devient de un espèce de
d'outils intéressants pour un robot
comme persévérance qui est sur Mars en
ce moment s'il y avait mettons un high
qui lui permet de faire déjà son mapping
par lui-même de suite la définition de
c'est comme oui c'est pas ce qu'on a
parce que nous on est toujours un peu en
arrière en technologie parce qu'il faut
qu'on soit vraiment prouvé mais comme là
est capable de ce conduire soi-même mais
c'est une forme de
on est en train de justement il y a un
changement de logiciel qu'on va qui va
être fait son émission bientôt qui va
lui permettre aussi de faire ses propres
décisions genre si je lui dis ok en
disant 11 heures tu fais ça en 11 ans à
midi tu fais ça voilà jusqu'à 4h mais
disons que fini de faire toutes ces
activités à 2h30 donc il peut dire ok
ben le choix des roches autour de moi
celle-là elle a l'air intéressant
laisse-moi donc prendre les données que
les renvoyer vers la terre fait que le
robot va être capable de faire certaines
missions comme ça
ici puis lui il leur reçoit
les fichiers c'est comme on voit les
fichiers parents
[Rires]
c'est fou pareil
ne marche pas sur un mais
tu es en pratique si sur terre aussi on
est des copies
de pas du robot on a une copie du robot
complète oui la seule il y a quelques
petites différences mais où il y en a on
a un champ de mars puis on a une copie
du robot puis on peut se pratiquer avec
ça nous permet de photos de pratiquer
à chaque fois dans le fond à chaque fois
vous avez quelque chose plus quand on
fait des choses de nouveau
sinon ça serait long
mais c'est comme les premiers jours sur
Mars on les avait pratiqué à l'avance là
si on fait un changement de logiciel le
premier échantillon bon on va se
pratiquer la première fois qu'on fait
quelque chose comme le quand on va
utiliser le nouveau logiciel de prendre
la décision on va se pratiquer et que
c'est pour entraîner pour être sûr que
le logiciel marche bien mais aussi pour
entraîner les humains qui font les
opérations un peu des deux incroyable
comment à moins que d'habitude
par rapport non mais par rapport mais je
me demandais s'il y avait d'autres si
c'était quoi mettons
tes projets de rêve mettons dans le
futur mettons des missions sur
lesquelles tu aimerais travailler ou des
trucs
j'avais travaillé sur une étude de cette
mission là comme quand j'ai commencé à
la NASA puis elle s'est jamais passé
mais peut-être un jour en fait il y a
une autre Lune autour de il y a une lune
autour de Saturne cette fois-ci qui
s'appelle en salade
l'une d'eau fait que de l'eau il y a une
croûte de glace mais il y a comme des
gros Gisors dans dans qui sortent comme
dans l'espace puis la mission qui a
signé avait passé justement elle avait
vu elle avait vu cette hola avait étudié
la planète mais c'était pas préparé à
trouver ça c'est la découverte
de la lune avec
découvert cette lune là mais pas pu
l'utiliser plus que ça mais c'est une
autre place l'astomiologie serait super
intéressante puis encore un peu plus
facile parce que là tu as pas besoin de
creuser pour aller pêcher ta viennent
juste ton petit filet
est en surface
super intéressante dans le fond c'est
Europe c'est là dans le fond c'est les
deux qui ont c'est dans le fond jusqu'à
date c'est les deux seules places qu'on
sait qu'il y a de l'eau liquide je pense
qu'il pense peut-être que Triton là
aussi en dessous
et puis là il y a des théories que mais
oui mais il y a d'autres de toutes
sortes d'autres lunes bien intéressantes
comme le Titan autour de autour de
Saturne où il pleut de la méthane pour y
aller
il y a une atmosphère encore plus
épaisse que la nôtre on a atterri sur
Titan encore avec kasny il y avait mais
c'était un petit atterrissage de rien
qui est bête c'est juste avec un
parachute quand on a quand un atmosphère
épais comme ça qui atterri sur Titan
pour étudier la surface survécu comme
quelques minutes mais
là il va avoir c'est pas nous c'est une
autre un autre centre de la NASA qui
vont envoyer un hélicoptère Titan dans
dans une dizaine d'années aussi pour
pour étudier ça puis mettons on sait que
qu'on peut imaginer que la vie peut être
complètement différente et nous on est
un peu fait ta base d'eau mais peut-être
que du monde fait à base de m'étonnes
d'habitude oui mais la méthode c'est
intéressant parce que oui c'est du
carbone fait que puis si tu es la
méthode vous avez créé par le processus
biologique la méthode sur Terre avec
une des choses qui n'entendait mais
surtout des vaches
mais les vaches en crée beaucoup
beaucoup d'ailleurs c'est une des choses
c'est pour ça que ça crée que les vaches
les gens des olives vaches affectent le
changement climatique ça cause du métal
mais
c'est ça fait que tu dis ok est-ce qu'il
y a un processus biologique qui peut
créer ce Méthanos sur Titan ou est-ce
que ben justement est-ce qu'il y aurait
pu comme nous on est on est une vie à
base d'eau à ce qui est les gens pensent
qu'ils pourraient aussi avoir une vie à
base de méthane
puis pour un autre endroit dans le
système solaire qui est intéressant
Vénus dans le passé avait aussi des
ressemblances
comme on s'est dit c'est que c'est aussi
dans cette zone de Boucle d'Or ou juste
au bord de la zone de Boucle d'Or le
ressemblait à terre Vénus en fait en
tant que est presque la même grandeur
que la terre c'est presque notre jumelle
sauf que ce qui s'est passé sur sur
Vénus et ce qui s'appelle en anglais le
run away green house effect mais ça
pourrait arriver sur terre aussi c'est
que l'effet l'effet de serre en fait
santé
par lui-même c'est parce que là tu as
des gaz qui garde l'infrarouge sur terre
puis ça devient plus chaud à cause de ça
qui crée plus de gaz qui gagne c'est ça
que c'est passé sur Vénus de manière
naturelle ça peut être affecté par
personne mais avec une planète
complètement inhabitable maintenant que
des pressions très très hautes fait très
très chaud à cause de cette fatière là
mais c'est intéressant qui a créé ses
effets de
mais avec c'est intéressant d'étudier
Vénus parce qu'encore là c'est un autre
exemple de planètes terrestre qu'on
appelle une planète rocheuse mais aussi
parce que quelque chose de complètement
différent
c'est missions dans les dizaines des 10
prochaines années plus ou moins qui vont
être lancés le une du jetpopashion là
qui s'appelle véritable puis une autre
je pense égale qui va envoyer ça
en orbite
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui explique que on
l'envoie en orbite on est prêt mais on
veut parce qu'on a aucune idée si on
peut atterrir dessus
sur Vénus ça me semble mais c'est juste
que les pressions sont très très hautes
puis il y a des concepts aussi de pour
atterrir quelque chose mais si c'est
complètement différent c'est intéressant
c'est une question c'est pourquoi est-ce
qu'on s'intéressait à mars parce que
Vénus
c'est pas c'est plus facile à atterrir
sur Mars c'est un peu comme ça revient
la guerre froide un peu aussi si on
dirait que les virus se sont beaucoup
intéressés à atterrir sur Vénus ils ont
fait les premiers atterrissages les
premières aberrations de Vénus puis nous
on a réussi en premier sur Mars fait
conséquent axé dans cette direction-là
c'est sûr que quand on parle de la
recherche la vie mais mars un peu plus
intéressant pour ce moment mais
des gens de la communauté scientifique
de Vénus qui écoute ça c'est comme c'est
eux intéressantes c'est c'est aussi un
peu la grandeur des communautés
scientifiques où est-ce que c'est un peu
c'est vraiment comme beaucoup de
politique où est-ce qu'on va
mais je pense que même si mars c'est
comme la deuxième planète la plus proche
Vénus est plus proche c'est un peu plus
facile à atterrir là
la question mettons
auquel de ton vivant tu aimerais avoir
la réponse c'est celle-là est-ce que la
vieille je pense qu'on a une bonne
chance d'être capable de répondre ça va
être bizarre si on s'en rend compte que
tu penses que ça va changer
pour nous ici dans Comment qu'on
les gens vont vraiment y croire ça va
être intéressant on a de la misère à
croire
au changement climatique
ça va bouleverser quand même c'est tout
ce qui est religion tout ce qui est
toute seule mais tais-toi en tant
qu'individuel c'est la compréhension ta
position dans l'univers c'est qu'elle
était pas toute seule ça change quand
même quelque chose
mais oui ça va être intéressant à voir
genre comment ça ça change les balances
de pouvoir dans le monde sait que se
crée toute ta vie que tu viens là
derrière puis que là on dit qu'il y a de
la vie ailleurs
avec les informations qu'on a déjà sur
la création
très religieux petit que son capable de
c'est pas toutes les religions toutes
formes de régions non plus qui dit que
tu peux remettre les doigts ensemble
peut-être la même petite c'est entre tu
peux décider d'adhérer un certain code
de valeur puis des coutumes sans
nécessairement
[Musique]
mais ça va prendre des bonnes preuves
pour vraiment démontrer que Nabilla
avant de te laisser partir juste un
petit mot comment ça va sur le lancement
de ton livre tu es content de la
réception est-ce que les gens
t'entendent beaucoup mais là j'étais au
salon du livre cette semaine
c'est bizarre parce que moi je le sais
pas trop quoi je peux ici
dans une dans une librairie pour voir
mon livre encore
même si ça fait un mois et demi mais
tu es le nombre de gens qui m'ont écrit
pour me dire que ça leur toucher ou qui
ont appris quelque chose c'est ça a été
très très positif et que mais je
m'attendais même pas à cette réception
là je pense quand j'écris les livres
c'était comme c'était vraiment juste
pour partager mon histoire et puis
peut-être inspirer une personne ici là
mais ça a été super bien reçu je pense
que on va voir à moitié c'est super
intéressant c'est vraiment super cool
puis tu es là on a parlé beaucoup de
d'espace puis de de mes petites par
beaucoup de de ton histoire et puis tu
as grandi à Joliette c'est une famille
tu sais d'origine indienne qui a vécu
mettait quand même un parcours
particulier à La Londe aux États-Unis
enfin puis toutes les les embûches que
tu as que tu as vécu à travers du chemin
puis on préfère tout un tout autre
podcast au complet juste sur ton
histoire fascinant puis je pense
justement effectivement que que
ça peut les inspirer à suivre comme tout
à fait ouais j'ai vraiment je voulais
vraiment partager comme une partie de
moi qu'on je parle peut-être moins en
entrevue qui montrait aux gens qui
étaient
premièrement être immigrants de quoi ça
a l'air mais aussi être scientifique de
quoi ça a l'air puis que c'est pas juste
comme l'idée qu'on a d'une personne qui
est un certain chemin puis qui se
retrouve là c'est important aussi de
parler comme les échecs des difficultés
de de se retrouver soi-même c'est un peu
comme innovation comme moi comment je me
suis retrouvée là mais avec avec des
fêtes récentes mais je l'ai écrit quand
je l'écris j'ai dit ça ma mère j'ai dit
je l'écris pour que ma mère puisse
comprendre puis ma mère est prof tu sais
mais elle était prof de français au
primaire fait que tu sais c'est pas la
science oui tu es un peu comprendre mais
tu sais c'est pas c'est pas son fort
même que des fois elle décroche quand
j'y parle fait que mais c'est je l'ai
vraiment écrit pour que tu es monsieur
et madame tout
il y a plein de concepts que j'avais
déjà entendu mais tu sais que c'est
quand même des French puis
c'est intéressant les choses avancent
est bonne justement entre les côtés plus
scientifiques puis de ton histoire
humaine qui est vraiment fascinante
aussi Jésus fan à l'écrire
dans quel temps
mais tu sais que ce livre-là écrivait
pas des livres comme je l'ai écrit parce
que moi j'ai eu le contrat du livre en
avril 2021 mais c'est là que c'est là
que les éditions là m'ont contacté
c'était comme leur idée
je pense que j'ai dû signer le contrat
comme l'été 2021 puis bon ok le 4 avril
2022 il faut que tu nous ramènes une
copie manuscrit mais la fille elle a pas
commencé à prendre le premier janvier
2022 à l'écrire son livre
qui faisait la cuisine puis il y avait
pas le droit de me donner un souper
avant que j'écris
en ayant aucune énergie parce que t'as
pas mangé de mort
[Rires]
le gars qui écrit ça que tu sais ça te
force à sortir mais le mot que ça soit
de la merde ou non tu sors puis après ça
c'est correct le plus difficile c'est
mettre ces mille mots là puis après tu
t'arranges avec lui
merci beaucoup
c'était vraiment cool
on a bien compris
merci beaucoup